c'est un mur qui n'empêchera pas
l'immigration clandestine et le
prolonger ne fait qu'enfler la polémique
george bush a promulgué une loi
autorisant la construction d'un mur long
d'un millier de kilomètres le long de la
frontière mexicaine décision que
condamnent aujourd'hui le nouveau
président mexicain reportage signé alain
de chalvron et pascal joue friot voilà
san diego au bord du pacifique une des
villes les plus agréables à vivre et les
plus prospères des états unis et voilà
tijuana un million deux cent mille
habitants ville de misère et de trafics
à la frontière américano-mexicaine
entre les deux le mur c'est en fait une
double palissade avec au milieu un no
man's land patrouillées par les gardes
frontières entre san diego et tijuana le
mur existe depuis des années mais il est
sans cesse renforcées et surtout
rallongé à terme il devrait courir sur
plus de 40% de la frontière du pacifique
au golfe du mexique n'est pas une bonne
chose un mur au contraire ça n'apporte
que des divisions pour moi un mur c'est
le mur de berlin
voilà ce que je pense imaginez que tout
le monde veut aller aux états unis
n'importe quoi
pas plus que les américains voudraient
venir au mexique le mur n'est pas que ce
grillage c'est aussi une défense
électronique des projecteurs des caméras
fixes des caméras mobiles à infrarouge
opéré depuis peu par l'armée la garde
nationale
j'ai vous dire cela on a pas mal de
caméras 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
et dites-vous bien que si vous essayez
passé on vous verra là où il existe le
mur aurait fait baisser de 75 % le
nombre des clandestins et à l'autre bout
de la californie on s'en est bien rendu
compte plus de main d'oeuvre les poires
ont pourri sur place un vrai désastre
pour les producteurs
nous n'avons récolté que la moitié de ce
verger
nous n'avons pas trouvé assez de main
d'oeuvre je pense qu'il serait
probablement venu si le mur n'avait pas
été aussi dissuasif
il y en a que quelques-uns qui ont
choisi de passer comme nous sommes
la plupart des agriculteurs ne veulent
pas trop penser à l'avenir
mais beaucoup pensent déjà arraché les
arbres pour d'autres types de cultures
qui demandent moins de main-d'oeuvre
sets à 2 poires qui pourrissent c'est le
prix à payer pour un mur dont la raison
essentielle est de calmer une peur
irrationnelle de l'autre